In this master class, I'm going to show
you how supply and demand works at the
deepest level and why mastering it
completely transformed my own trading
results and will change yours, too. By
the end of this video, you will
understand all these concepts and be
able to find trades based on supply and
demand. And later, I'll tell you about a
$20,000 trading competition prize pool
that you can join for free. So let's
talk about the theory of supply and
demand first. And so if we're looking at
just like let's say a market of gold.
Well, as the price of gold is really
low, there's going to be a low supply of
it because there's not that many people
wanting to sell it. Why would I sell,
you know, this gold bar that I think is
valuable for a really low amount of
money? But as the price gets really
high, more and more people are going to
think, well, hey, I want to sell my bar
of gold because I can get a lot of money
for it because the price of it is really
high. I'm getting a lot of value. But
then on the flip side, for demand, well,
if something's really, really expensive,
like a bar of gold, I'm not going to
want it because I don't want to pay that
much money for something I think I can
get for a lesser value later. And so as
time goes on and as the price goes down,
demand actually increases. And so you
have imbalances where supply can be
really high, but no one wants to
actually buy it because it's overvalued
or times where demand is really high,
but nobody wants to sell it because they
don't want to sell it for dirt cheap.
And so in the middle here, that's where
you have more of an equilibrium where
buyers and sellers meet. And so when it
comes to actually trading, what you can
have is and what you create is supply
and demand zones. based on stuff that
we'll talk about in a minute of how you
identify these. But based on past
observations, you can start to create
these and know that okay, well, when the
price comes down to this demand zone,
it's likely that it's oversold, that the
price is so cheap that there's likely to
be a high demand, which will over time
increase the price because more and more
people want to buy it. And so the supply
actually starts to dry up. And so if
there's a finite amount of something,
the price is going to go up over time as
more and more people buy it and more and
more people want it. But eventually it's
going to get to a point where it's at a
price where more people want to start to
sell it because they can get a really
high amount of money for it. And so the
price will go down. And so quite often
you'll hit these extreme areas and have
strong moves off of them and then you'll
get into that more middle ground between
the two where it has that equilibrium
and it'll have more of a choppy market.
And so this is why when you look at a
stock chart, it's important to
understand that these extremes are the
important part to pay attention to
because you'll likely have the market
bounce off these zones quickly and like
I said, chop around in the middle and
then it will once it comes up to a
level, you have that potential to
reverse off of it. And so that's how you
want to look at trading these levels.
And so this is how I like to use them
for trading is I like to watch for key
areas where I think that the market
might find a supply or demand and it's
likely to reverse off of the supply and
demand zone and then you can capture a
nice swing off of that. In this trade
right here, the market came down to this
demand zone down here and I bought, went
long and captured a move up and made
about $1,500 on this trade. And then as
it came up to where I thought there was
another supply zone, I got out of the
trade because it's likely that it
reverses off that zone and I wanted to
get out of my profitable trade and move
on with my day. Now, this is horizontal
supply and demand zones. What you can
actually have is trending supply and
demand zones where the market is moving
down slowly and it continues to move
lower over time. But what you get is it
starts to bounce off of supply and
demand zones as it creates those. And so
you can start to take trades as it tests
these levels. Another way to do this is
it can actually be created with more
trend lines. And so every time it comes
up to that trend line, you can think of
it as a supply zone. It's just more
horizontal. A good example of this is a
trade I took recently where the market
had a demand trend level down here that
I wanted to take a trade off of. And so
it bounced around, moved up higher, and
then sold off to that level to where I
thought, okay, it's likely that the
market starts to slow down here. Waited
for a setup that I like. a few key
patterns that I look for every time that
I'll talk about in a little while to
enter in, confirm the trade, and then I
waited for it to play out, and it
eventually played out, moving up to the
higher end of the range, and I was able
to get out for a clean $1,200 trade
pretty quickly. And so, that's how I use
supply and demand because it's so
powerful to simplify trading. There's so
many indicators and concepts when it
comes to trading and I always found the
best way is to focus on just one or two
things and supply and demand really
change that around for me. So I want to
talk to you about the key concepts that
I use every time I draw a supply and
demand zone so I know that it's actually
powerful and it's likely that the market
actually reverses off of it. Otherwise,
it's so easy going into our first
concept. It's so easy to draw supply
levels everywhere and not know which
ones are going to hold and which ones
are going to break. And so for me, the
first biggest thing is not looking at
those levels in the middle of the range.
I like to stick to then at an extreme of
that supply and demand in the market
versus being in that middle of that area
and you could have a chop and just not
have something that's worth taking a
trade. And so that's the first key
concept is stick to extremes in the
market. I always find that for my
trades, even though I have a, you know,
a three to fivestep checklist I look for
every time I enter into a trade, it
doesn't matter if everything on a one
minute chart is aligning up perfectly
and it looks like it's going to have a
great trade. If the big picture isn't
aligned and saying like, hey, yeah, I
think that we could bounce to the upside
or that we're at a extreme where the
overall price is likely to have a snap
back, then there's no trade. This is the
most important thing when it comes to
executing and confirming my trades is
things being at an extreme and also the
big picture being aligned with what I
think is going to happen. Now, when it
comes to drawing these zones, what I
like to do is I like to see at a minimum
multiple touches. So, in terms of here,
there's this swing right here and then
there's these two touches right here.
And so, what I did was I said, "Okay,
hey, I think you know when the market
was trending nearly where it is right
now with that bounce we just saw, I go
back multiple this is me going back
almost a month in data to find this
level." And so I go based off of okay,
we have the extreme down here and then
we've also got a couple of bounces here.
It looks like we kind of had a head and
shoulders here, but essentially there's
some chop in here and some bounces. And
so that's I think okay, it's you know
why I draw a zone and then I'm just
going to drag it across here to where
essentially the current price is. And as
the market came down here, I said,
"Okay, I think it's likely we bounce off
of here." and then it gets a nice really
clean double bottom and then I go into a
smaller time frame and look to see if
there's a nice setup right here and I
can catch a big swing higher. And so the
reason why I draw zones instead of very
specific lines for my horizontal levels
is because it's a supply and demand
zone. You don't know where exactly it's
going to bounce. It's going to bounce
somewhere in this area. Every time the
market comes down and tests a level,
things are going to slightly change.
Maybe the market will come down here and
barely test it here because in this
instance when it's coming down to this
level, well, there's some news out or
for some reason a lot of people want to
buy it now and it's going to bounce way
sooner or it pushes further down. people
are less interested in buying it until
it gets to an even deeper extreme and
then that imbalance happens and people
swoop in, pick it up quickly and then it
rockets up. And so that's why you can
see there's a big rocket in this case.
And so that leads into our next concept
is when there is a massive move off of a
level, I like to key into that as well
because if there is really aggressive
buying or selling, it means that a lot
of people came in in the buying side,
there was a lot of demand. And so it
makes it more likely that when it comes
back in the future, people are going to
want to buy it. or on the flip side, if
there's a big selling, it makes it more
likely that people are going to want to
sell when it comes up to this area. Now,
most of the time, I like to just look at
the last few days for a lot of my levels
because that's the most recent price
action, and it's more likely that
something's going to happen based off of
that. If you zoom really far out and you
have a level all the way from back here,
when the market touches that again
months later, I find that a lot of the
time something has changed at that
point. And if it comes all the way down
here, I'm going to look for that to
potentially break. So, I've got a free
downloadable PDF that talks you through
the five concepts that I use for every
supply and demand level I draw. You can
download it in the description or this
QR code. I highly recommend getting it
as a easy resource to look back on when
you really understand these concepts
from this video. Now, let's talk about
some keys of how do you know to the best
of your judgment? Because you never
truly know and can never truly confirm
if a supply or demand level is going to
hold is it's how the market comes into
that level. And so you have multiple
trends where either you have a very
fastpaced extreme aggressive move or you
have a healthy trend with methodical
pullbacks where it sometimes even breaks
the trend, moves around, chops, touches
the zone and then continues to chop a
little bit. But essentially how I see it
is when the market has a very fast-paced
move like this, it's more likely to
bounce at a zone just like this move
right here. And the reason why is
because it's an unhealthy move. The
market when it just has an unhealthy
move in general, even if there isn't a
supply or demand zone, it needs some
kind of pullback to create that
equilibrium. And when it hits that
extreme of this supply and demand theory
graph, there's going to be so much
supply in the market, if we quickly go
back to the concept here, is because if
it shoots down so fast, there's some
crazy momentum pushing it and pushing
and forcing price to be so cheap down
here. But at some point when it gets so
cheap, people are going to start buying
it and sellers are going to eventually
start to dry up and you will have what
is called a Vbottom. And so you have
that right here. In this case, it
actually did almost a double Vbottom
where it came down, spiked, supply kind
of push it down lower one more time, and
then as it hit here again, people came
in and said, "No, this is a amazing
price." And it rockets up from there.
And so this is how a volatile market
works because supply and demand is all
over the place and that is really really
good for trading when a a and for likely
that a level will hold. Now, sometimes
you'll have it to where it just blows
through a level, and those are easy to
avoid. And that's why one thing is,
we'll get to my checklist in a minute of
why you have a reasons that you look out
for to jump in and buy in an area like
this. You don't just blindly say, "Hey,
I'm going to put in a limit order down
here, a buy order that when this price
comes down here, if it does, I just want
to get long no matter what it looks like
because I think it's likely to go up."
Well, that's not always true because
supply can be so powerful that it blows
right through this level and you have to
look at the next level. And so those
unhealthy trends when they do start to
lose a little momentum, I find it's
likely that it reverses and those are
the best trades. Now, when a zone is
more likely to break is if maybe we can
find a quick one here is this was a
pretty good zone right here. You know,
this was the zone I was watching for a
while. We had multiple touches up here.
You could even drag it down and take
this swing. This is a clear swing where
it came up to that zone, bounced off. We
had a lot of chop up here. It eventually
sold off. And when the market came up
here again, well, I'm looking at the big
picture. And so the big picture is we've
come down, sold off, there was a big
news that caused a spike. The whole time
after that news, the market was just
kind of chopping back and forth. And
well, pattern-wise, this is a this is a
bull flag right here. And if you look at
the lows, they're essentially getting
higher and higher. Every time after the
first couple times, the market would
make a push up here. The swing low would
get higher and higher. And what that
means is people are coming in and buying
the extremes that where it gets pushes
to the downside sooner and sooner. And
so as it starts to in my eyes has a
healthy move up here where there's moves
with ups and pullbacks and it starts to
kind of sit here and you know it kind of
sat here and chopped around for a while
and it sold off and then it comes up
here and starts to sit here again. To
me, that makes it way more likely that
it continues higher. And this is
actually one of the trades we looked at
a minute ago that I just quickly showed.
This is where that trend line of
trending supply and demand worked out as
well. You can also see as the moves move
up, it creates those with the swings.
And so this is the cleanest one right
here where it popped up, sold off a
little. And so you could say, well, this
is a micro supply level. Came back down
to here, broke that, hit another supply
level. It was kind of the highs at this
point. Big area where it's likely to
sell off, sold off. And then at this
point, you have multiple touches here to
where I drew this trend line. This was
actually before market opens where it
came up and it hit this demand trend
line and also hit this previous say
supply level that turned into a demand
level. So that's the interesting thing
as well is levels when they're broken
can flip. And so in this case, and this
happens all the time where you have a
high and then the market breaks that and
it comes back and tests that high. And
you can see this all over the market. If
you just zoom out and kind of look, you
can see here's another concept of it
happening where the market came up here,
put in a high, kind of sold off a little
bit, broke above that, and then if you
pretty much just draw these highs, it
came up, bounced off of it, and made an
attempt to keep going higher before the
market started selling off rest of this
day. And so that's where when I'm
looking at the market come up into a
level in a healthy way into either a
supply or demand level, I think it's
more likely to break that zone and I
will avoid betting to the downside. And
so even though the market came up to
this extreme level that I was watching
and instead of betting to the downside,
I said, "Okay, I'm not betting to the
downside. I'm just going to sit out on
that potential trade." and I looked to
take this long right here, betting that
the market was going to break and go
higher. Now, to tell you about the prize
pool, Ninja Trader, the platform I use
here, is having a $20,000
trading competition. You can join with a
demo account, basically risk-free trade
in this competition. It lasts for 5
days, so it's actually over pretty
quick. starting September 14th, which is
a sick way to practice trading in a
risk-free environment, but also be able
to make some real money to start a
trading account for yourself. So, you
can sign up for that using the link
below or this QR code. Now, let's go
into how I confirm off these levels
talking about this trade actually. And
so the first thing that I always use for
every trade that it has to have is that
supply or demand zone. I want it to come
up to a extreme or come down to an
extreme. Now with this case in this
trade, it's a little bit more of a
complex nuance to it that I hope you can
use and take to your trading. Otherwise,
the super simple version is coming down
to these levels and looking for a clear
double bottom and jumping in on a
smaller time frame chart that we are
going to talk about right now. And so
that's number one is having that level
and having an understanding of the big
picture of why in this case why I didn't
want to take a short to the downside and
I actually wanted to take a trade to the
upside which is the biggest key when it
comes to trading. A lot of people that
try and use this strategy they'll just
follow this checklist and they will
actually get into spots where they
shouldn't because they're going against
the big picture of the market. big
picture is what is going to allow you to
capture big moves like this versus
coming into, you know, some kind of
level and thinking that it's going to do
something else when, you know, the big
picture isn't really there. And so I
start out every morning opening the
markets at 7:30 my time, which is the
market open for the US stock market. And
so this strategy and all these supply
and demand levels you can use on really
any market or time frame, but I like to
use them on the futures markets. I'm not
going to jump into that too much right
now. I have a whole video on how to
understand how futures work. But
basically what I like to do is when the
market opens at 7:30, I like to see some
kind of movement. And I like to see it
make that drastic move in one direction
because again thinking about what I just
talked about, those unhealthy moves are
likely to have good bounces versus the
healthy methodical moves are likely to
continue in a healthy methodical way.
Now, they totally can reverse. And I
will take trades based on those
sometimes, but it's a lot trickier and
easier to get in a bad spot doing that.
And so, as the market came down to this
area, to this supply and demand trend
line, that bigger picture one is this
line right here. And so, again, I even
though on my chart I have a a specific
line, it's kind of harder to draw a
trending zone like I have these, but I
think of it as the same concept. If it's
coming down to this area somewhere,
that's a good enough for me. It's going
to likely bounce somewhere in that area.
And so what I looked for was it to
create essentially a head and shoulders
pattern. Once you kind of go into these
smaller charts, all the trends and
concepts work the same way because the
candlesticks are basically telling the
same story but just on a different time
frame and a different pace. And so
that's why it's important to use a
bigger picture and a 15-minute time
frame to look at, okay, what is the big
picture of what's going on and then I
like to go into the smaller picture and
go from there. But every trade I look at
and you'll look at the and if you look
at my live trading videos across my
channel, you will see pretty much every
trade looks the same. And that's the
best thing and the way I realized to be
profitable for me is to just try and
repeat the exact same thing every day.
It's boring, but it works. And that's
all that matters when it comes to
trading. We're trying to make money,
right? And so what I look for is when it
comes down to this level, I want to see
a head and shoulders pattern.
Essentially what that shows is it shows
the swings in the market starting to
shift and it shows that this momentum to
the downside is slowing down. And so
here I was looking at this form right
here and I said, "Okay, I like this.
This big bare candlestick is almost like
a final harrah of sellers trying to push
the price lower." And then when this big
bullish candlestick comes in and and
reverses that almost in a blink of an
eye, I say, "Hey, that's a really good
fake lower traps people to the downside
if more people try and go short." And I
like to get in with a buy stop order as
it breaks above this high because I like
to get in based on momentum because I
think, well, if I'm getting in on
momentum, that's when the demand is
starting to pick up. you can avoid
sitting in this chop like this and you
can capture the easier move in the
market. Now, when it comes to trading,
you don't have to capture, you know, you
don't have to get in perfectly at the
bottom or perfectly at the top and sell
perfectly at the bottom. All you have to
do is really for me, I get in it, you
know, if the swing is going to go from
here to here, I'm getting in and
capturing this part. I'm getting maybe
half of the move. But with how trading
works, it's not about capturing a large
move. It's capturing some of that move
and increasing your sizing. I used to
trade where I was risking $100 per
trade. And a huge trade for me would be
this much right here, $300. And now my
sizing has increased. And that's how you
make more money trading to where you're
risking $500, $2,000 per trade. and
going just a small amount in the market
can be a lot of money. And so I don't
want to get too much into managing the
trade, but the rough concepts I like to
use is the same reason why I get in.
What are the trend line doing? Where
does it look like there's potential
supply and demand when it comes to
managing? I like to focus on the one
minute time frame patterns. Of course, I
think the big picture is going to push
higher over the day, but you can have a
lot of big swings on a smaller time
frame to make that happen. And so, when
it comes to trading and making money,
I'm just looking for a a scalp really.
And I'm just looking for it to make a
move up in a really a small way. And
this trade here was tricky. It it was
kind of choppy. The market's been really
tricky lately. and it just kind of
started to slowly grind lower. And I
tried to be liberal with my stop loss
and give it a lot of wiggle room because
I thought, hey, I really like this
level. It's come down here and showed
this really nice pattern. And if it
needs to come down here and like we just
talked about, this could be the new
demand level that was previously the
supply level that these big candlesticks
were pushing off of and instead it's
broken above that. Maybe it's going to
come down here, test it, and then push
higher. And so that's the hard part
about trading too is adjusting to what
kind of market you're in. And in the
market that this trade was in and the
market currently is is it's in a lot
more slow methodical movement. And so
from there, patience paid off and I was
able to let the trade ride out and it
moved up to pretty much two times my
risk. I was risking about $600 on this
trade and I got $1,200 in about 40
minutes. And this is something I repeat
every single morning. Now, I highly
recommend watching this technical
analysis video right after this. It'll
dive in even more about understanding
structure and market patterns. And if
you couple that with this supply and
demand, you will drastically increase
how you understand to read charts and it
will accelerate your trading immensely.